the first color we're going to talk
about is blue the most common color
among the Jedi they are often wielded by
Jedi Guardians who focus on combat
skills and physical abilities the second
color is green another popular choice
among the Jedi they are usually wielded
by Jedi Consolers who specialize in
diplomacy healing and force knowledge
the third color is red the signature
color of the Sith and other Dark Side
users they are created by a process
called bleeding where a dark side user
bends a kyber crystal to their will the
fourth color is yellow a rare and unique
color among the Jedi they're wielded by
Jedi Sentinels who combine combat skills
and force knowledge with practical
skills and stealth the fifth color is
purple a very rare and special color
among the Jedi they are usually wielded
by Jedi who have a strong connection to
both the light and the dark sides of the
force the sixth color is white the color
that's not naturally found in kyber
crystals they are created by a process
called purification where a lights side
user heals a blood kyber Crystal the
seventh and final color is black a color
that's exclusive to one lightsaber in
the entire galaxy the dark saber